my name is Joshua I'm in sixth grade and
I'm an expert on speed stacking we are
cup stacking never heard of it it's like
get cups and you stack them I'm going to
be learning the three six three it's
where you have six cups in the middle
and you have three cups on the side and
then you have to stack three and six and
three when I'm time I go and I'll be
done in less than five seconds BAM
so what do you do I do a thing called
speed stacking I learned from my sister
when she was in fourth grade she brought
home a stack of cups and then she taught
me how to do it cup stacking means to me
like just just a fun thing to do and
then I got good at it do you think you
could teach us in 15 minutes
yeah I think you guys can do pretty good
if you get it right he's legit guys take
one cup and the other cup and yeah
exactly like that and then for the six
you want to take three cups in one hand
three and Kabu in the other hand no
that's
three this is challenging yeah yeah and
another comes down and when you're ready
you go back to the beginning and take
the top cop in the other Cup yeah shoot
whoa then you can sat down after great
awesome
seventeen awesome I can't believe it
this is fun
Oh miss really fun let's get a little
frustrating but I really at least want
to get the twenty orem you know maybe
even 15 mil 14 so let's go and by the
way do thinking you're being very
patient with someone he's pretty bad at
this let's do this
Kyra do good cuz she's like crazy and
fast buddy Ivan he's gonna do really
good
Kelly I think she's very mature so I
think she'll take it pretty seriously I
don't know about Toby it's gonna be a
question
I'm as competitive as Ned so I'm going
to be great at this
my whole body is buzzing right now until
they really want to take this one home
go
and the winner is Tyra and the winner is
Kaley good game buddy you did a good job
just gonna be like and have to showdown
but it's gonna be like very
nerve-wracking and stuff like that we
never know we just have to believe in
herself right yeah we can do this Kaley
and the winner is Tyra I learned a new
skill today like a new hobby that I
could do when I was alone with Josh um I
thought I would make it because I had a
lot of mistakes you know but then for
the competition I just knew I could do
it so I didn't think I was gonna make it
to the finals finals but if you just
believe you could achieve I'm Josh again
you were amazing bro thank you for
coming thank you for coming drum he'll
go thank you a new kale sudden